We think of our lives as a series of events, of things happening one after another. But, you know, it's just as accurate to see our lives as a series of things that don't happen to us. There's this story where all the crucial action takes place within just a short bike ride from the spot where I speak to you from right now, here in Chicago. The setting, a summer, much like the one we're living through even as I speak, on this humid, midwestern day. It's a piece of fiction, a really, really great piece of fiction actually, by a writer named Stuart Dybek. We Didn't.
我们认为生活是一系列事件的发生，一件接一件。但你知道吗，把生活看作是一系列没有发生在我们身上的事情，也同样准确。有这样一个故事，所有关键情节都发生在我现在说话的地方——芝加哥，离这儿不远的一次短途骑行范围内。背景是一个夏天，就像我们此刻正在经历的这个，在这个潮湿的中西部日子里。这是一部虚构作品，实际上是一位名叫斯图尔特·戴贝克（Stuart Dybek）的作家写得非常、非常棒的虚构作品。题目是《我们没做》。
We didn't in the light. We didn't in darkness. We didn't in the fresh-cut summer grass, or in the mounds of autumn leaves, or in the snow, where moonlight threw down our shadows. We didn't in your room on the canopy bed you slept in, the bed you'd slept in as a child. Or in the backseat of my father's rusted Rambler, which smelled of the smoked chubs and kielbasa that he delivered on weekends for my Uncle Vincent's meat market. We didn't in your mother's Buick 8, where a rosary twined the rear view mirror like a beaded, black snake with silver, cruciform fangs.
我们没在光天化日之下做。我们没在黑暗中做。我们没在那修剪整齐的夏日草坪上做，也没在那秋叶堆中做，或者在雪地里做，那里的月光投射出我们的影子。我们没在你的房间里，在那张你睡过的顶篷床上做，那张你小时候睡过的床。也没在父亲那辆生锈的漫步者（Rambler）汽车后座做，那车里总有一股烟熏红点鲑和波兰香肠的味道，那是他周末为文森特叔叔的肉铺送货留下的。我们没在你母亲的别克8里做，那里的后视镜上缠着一串念珠，像一条带着银色十字架毒牙的黑色珠子蛇。
After this opening paragraph, Stuart Dybek has 11 pages, thousands of words, describing all of the things that two people can do when they're not doing something. Turns out, that not doing something is every bit as vivid and complicated an experience as doing something. But, my friend, where are the stories of the things that we do when we're not doing the thing itself? Well, we bring those to you today, right here. Part of our ongoing quest to document our actual lives in this country. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这段开场白之后，斯图尔特·戴贝克用11页纸、数千字描述了两个人不做某事时能做的所有事情。事实证明，不做某事和做某事一样，都是生动而复杂的经历。但是，朋友，那些我们不做某事时所做的事情的故事在哪里呢？好吧，我们今天就把它们带给你，就在这里。这是我们记录在这个国家真实生活持续探索的一部分。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台（PRI），这里是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme. Today's show, We Didn't.
当然，我们每周的节目都会选择一个主题。今天的节目是《我们没做》。
Act One, You Come And Go, The Waiters Remain in which we hear a few words from the D.H. Lawrence of not doing it.
第一幕，《你来去，侍者留》。在这一幕中，我们将听到几句来自“不做之事的D.H.劳伦斯”的感言。
Act Two, Dance. A scientific investigation by Mr. Danny Hoch into what exactly is happening between two people, step by step, moment by moment, when they're not falling in love.
第二幕，《舞蹈》。丹尼·霍克（Danny Hoch）先生的一项科学调查，深入研究了两个人之间究竟发生了什么——一步一步，一刻一刻——当他们没有坠入爱河的时候。
Act Three, Same Time Next Year. A couple nearly gets together, but does not. And then an uncanny coincidence intervenes, as in a fable, as in a dream, as in a movie. But what does it mean?
第三幕，《明年此时》。一对情侣差点在一起，但没有。接着，一个不可思议的巧合介入了，就像在寓言中，在梦中，在电影中一样。但这到底意味着什么？
Act Four, Saying No For 75 Years. The story of what happens when you say no to exactly the wrong person at the wrong time when you're 21 years old and looking at prison. Stay with us. Don't say no now.
第四幕，《拒绝了75年》。当你在21岁、面临牢狱之灾时，拒绝了一个绝对错误的人，会发生什么故事。请留下来。现在别拒绝。
Act One, You Come And Go, The Waiters Remain. We begin today's program with this story. It's a part story, part philosophical inquiry into the nature of not doing things from Geoff Dyer.
第一幕，《你来去，侍者留》。我们从这个故事开始今天的节目。这是一篇兼具故事和哲学探讨的文章，关于杰夫·戴尔（Geoff Dyer）笔下“不做之事”的本质。
For years, I wanted to write a book about D.H. Lawrence, a homage to the writer who'd made me want to become a writer. It was a cherished ambition. And as part of my preparation for realizing this cherished ambition, I'd avoided reading anything by Lawrence so that at some point in the future, I could go back to him, if not afresh, then at least not rock-stale. Then after years of avoiding Lawrence, I moved into the phase of what might be termed "pre-preparation."
多年来，我想写一本关于D.H.劳伦斯的书，向这位让我渴望成为作家的作家致敬。这是一个珍贵的抱负。为了实现这个珍贵的抱负，我做了些准备，我刻意避免阅读劳伦斯的任何作品，这样在未来的某个时刻，我就能以全新的——或者至少是不那么陈旧疲惫的眼光去读他。在避开劳伦斯多年后，我进入了可能被称为“预备阶段”的时期。
I visited Eastwood, his birthplace. I read biographies. I amassed a horde of photographs, which I kept in a once-new document wallet, blue, on which I had written "D.H.L. Photos" in determined, black ink. I even built up an impressive stack of notes with Lawrence vaguely in mind.
我参观了他的出生地伊斯特伍德，阅读了传记。我收集了一大堆照片，把它们放在一个曾经崭新的蓝色文件夹里，上面用坚定的黑色墨水写着“D.H.L.照片”。我甚至凭着对劳伦斯的模糊印象，积累了一叠令人印象深刻的笔记。
But these notes, it's obvious to me now, actually served not to prepare for and facilitate the writing of a book about Lawrence, but to defer and postpone doing so. There's nothing unusual about this. All over the world, people are taking notes as a way of postponing, putting off, and standing in for. My case was more extreme. For not only was taking notes about Lawrence a way of putting off writing a study of and homage to the writer who'd made me want to become a writer, but this study I was putting off writing was itself a way of putting off and postponing another book.
但现在很明显，这些笔记实际上并没有为写书做准备或提供便利，而是为了拖延和推迟这件事。这并不罕见。全世界的人都在通过做笔记的方式来拖延、推迟和替代本该做的事。我的情况更为极端。因为记录关于劳伦斯的笔记，不仅是推迟撰写这位让我渴望成为作家的研究和致敬之作的方式，而且这本我一直在推迟写的书，本身也是为了推迟和拖延另一本书。
Although I'd made up my mind to write a book about Lawrence, I'd also made up my mind to write a novel. Writing them both at the same time was inconceivable. And so these two equally overwhelming ambitions first wore each other down and then wiped each other out. As soon as I thought about working on the novel, I fell to thinking that it would be much more enjoyable to write my study of Lawrence. As soon as I started making notes on Lawrence, I realized I was probably sabotaging forever any chance of writing my novel, which, more than any other book I'd written, had to be written immediately before another protracted bout of labor came between me and the idea for what I perceived as a rambling, sub-Bernhardtian rant of a novel.
虽然我下定决心要写一本关于劳伦斯的书，但也下定决心要写一部小说。同时写这两本书是不可想象的。因此，这两个同样令人难以抗拒的雄心壮志，先是互相消耗，然后互相消灭。每当我想到要写小说时，我就觉得写关于劳伦斯的研究会更有趣。每当我开始做劳伦斯的笔记时，我就意识到我可能永远破坏了写小说的机会，而这部小说比我写过的任何其他书都更需要立即动笔，以免另一段漫长的劳作介入我与那个想法之间——那个我心目中凌乱、近乎伯恩哈德式的长篇大论的小说。
It was now or never. So I went from making notes on Lawrence to making notes for my novel, by which I mean I went from not working on my book about Lawrence to not working on the novel. Because all of this to-ing, and fro-ing, and note taking actually meant that I never did any work on either book. All I did was switch between two empty files on my computer, one conveniently called C:\DHL, the other C:\NOVEL, and sent myself pinging back and forth between them until, after an hour and a half of this, I would turn off the computer.
机不可失，失不再来。所以我从做劳伦斯的笔记转而去做小说的笔记，意思是说我从“不写关于劳伦斯的书”转变成了“不写小说”。因为所有这些来来回回的折腾和做笔记，实际上意味着我从来没有真正动笔写过任何一本书。我所做的只是在电脑上的两个空白文档之间切换，一个方便地命名为C:\DHL，另一个命名为C:\NOVEL，让自己在它们之间来回弹跳，直到一个半小时后，我就把电脑关了。
Because the worst thing of all, I knew, was to wear myself out in this way. The best thing was to do nothing, to sit calmly. But there was no calm of course. Instead, I felt totally desolate because I realized that I was going to write neither my study of D.H. Lawrence nor my novel.
因为我知道，最糟糕的事情就是这样耗尽自己。最好的办法是无所事事，冷静地坐着。但当然，根本没有平静可言。相反，我感到极其沮丧，因为我意识到我既不会写关于D.H.劳伦斯的研究，也不会写我的小说。
One of the reasons that it was impossible to get started on either the Lawrence book or the novel was because I was so preoccupied with where to live. I could live anywhere. There were no constraints on me. And because of this, it was impossible to choose. It's easy to make choices when you have things hampering you. A job, kid's schools. But when all you have to go on is your own desires, then life becomes considerably more difficult, not to say intolerable.
无法开始劳伦斯那本书或小说的一个原因是，我太专注于住在哪里了。我可以住在任何地方。我没有任何束缚。正因为如此，选择变得不可能。当你受困于工作、孩子学校等琐事时，做选择很容易。但当你只能依靠自己的欲望时，生活就变得相当困难，甚至无法忍受。
Even money wasn't an issue since, at this stage, I was living in Paris. And nowhere could have been more expensive than Paris. The exchange rate got worse by the month, and Paris became more expensive by the month. What the money situation in Paris did was to emphasize that although I had settled in Paris, really, I'd just been passing through extremely slowly.
甚至钱也不是问题，因为在这个阶段，我住在巴黎。没有什么地方比巴黎更昂贵了。汇率逐月恶化，巴黎的生活费逐月上涨。巴黎的财务状况强调了一点：虽然我在巴黎安顿下来，但实际上，我只是在极其缓慢地经过这里。
That is all anyone English or American can do in Paris, pass through. You may spend 10 years passing through, but essentially you're still a sightseer, a tourist. You come and go. The waiters remain.
这就是所有英国人或美国人在巴黎能做的事情：经过。你可能会花10年时间在这里经过，但本质上你仍然是一个观光客、游客。你来来去去。侍者们依然在那里。
The longer I stayed, the more powerful it became, this feeling that I was just passing through. I'd thought about subscribing to the cable channel, Canal Plus, as a way of making myself feel more settled. But what was the point in subscribing to Canal Plus when, in all probability, I would be moving on in a few months? Obviously, the way to make myself more settled was to acquire some of the trappings of permanence. But there never seemed any point acquiring the aptly-named trappings of permanence when, in a couple of months, I might be moving on, might well be moving on, would almost certainly be moving on?
我待的时间越长，这种“我只是经过”的感觉就越强烈。我曾考虑订阅有线频道Canal Plus，以此让自己感觉更安定些。但考虑到很可能几个月后我就会搬走，订阅Canal Plus又有什么意义呢？显然，让自己安顿下来的方法是获取一些“永恒的附属品”。但考虑到几个月后我可能就会搬走，获取那些恰如其名“永恒的附属品”似乎总是毫无意义，可能真的会搬走，而且几乎可以肯定会搬走。
Because there was nothing to keep me where I was. Had I acquired some of the trappings of permanence, I might have stayed put. But I never acquired any of the trappings of permanence because I knew that the moment these trappings had been acquired, I would seized with the desire to leave, to move on. And I would then have to free myself from these trappings. And so, lacking any of the trappings of permanence, I was perpetually on the brink of potential departure. That was the only way I could remain anywhere, to be constantly on the brink, not of actual, but of potential departure.
因为没有什么能留住我。如果我获取了一些永恒的附属品，我或许就能安顿下来。但我从来没有获取过任何永恒的附属品，因为我知道一旦拥有了这些东西，我就会被离开、搬走的欲望所攫住。然后我就不得不摆脱这些羁绊。所以，因为缺乏任何永恒的附属品，我永远处于即将离开的边缘。这是我能留在任何地方的唯一方式，那就是时刻保持在一种——不是实际上的，而是潜在的——离开的边缘。
These were all issues I intended to address in different ways, either in mediated form in my study of Lawrence, or directly in my novel, or vice versa. But there was an additional practical complication too. Since I was obliged to spend a certain amount of time away from wherever I lived, and since the rent on my Paris apartment was so high, and because of the exchange rate was becoming higher every month, I was frequently obliged to sublet it. Strictly speaking, to sub-sublet it since I was subletting it myself. And since if you are subletting your apartment, you do not want to acquire too many valuable or personal items, which might get destroyed, it then comes about that you, yourself, are living in conditions arranged primarily for those subletting from you.
这些都是我打算用不同方式解决的问题，要么以中介形式写在我的劳伦斯研究中，要么直接写在我的小说里，反之亦然。但还有一个实际的复杂因素。由于我必须在远离住所的地方待上一段时间，再加上巴黎公寓的租金很高，而且汇率每月都在上涨，我经常不得不转租它。严格来说，是转租给别人，因为我自己就是租客。而且由于转租公寓时，你不希望放置太多贵重或个人的物品以免损坏，结果就是你自己住在主要为转租客安排的环境中。
Effectively, you are subletting from yourself. That's what I was doing, subletting from myself. Strictly speaking, sub-subletting, living in an apartment devoid of anything that might have made it my apartment in the sense of "my home." I'd conspired to arrange for myself the worst of all possible worlds. And my days were spent in this unbreakable circle of anxiety, always going over the same ground again and again, always with some new variable, but never with any change.
实际上，你在从自己手里转租。我当时就在做这件事，从自己手中转租。严格来说，是二次转租，住在一间空荡荡的公寓里，没有任何东西能让它成为“我的家”。我合谋为自己安排了最糟糕的情况。我的日子就在这种无法打破的焦虑圈中度过，总是不断地重走旧路，总是带着一点新的变量，却从来没有任何改变。
I had to do something to break this circle. And so I decided to sign a contract that would make me the official tenant, as opposed to the illegal subtenant. I wasn't even sure that I wanted to stay in an apartment where I'd actually been extremely unhappy for 90% of my stay, where 90% of my stay had been dominated by anxiety about, A, whether I was going to stay, and B, whether I was going to start a novel or start my study of Lawrence. But as soon as the managing agent said that they were unwilling to let the place to me, a foreigner with no job and no steady income, I became convinced that I had to stay in this apartment where I'd actually been sublimely happy. That there was, in fact, nowhere else on earth where I could hope to be as content. Eventually, my rich friend, Herve Landry, "Money Landry," as I like to call him, agreed to stand as guarantor.
我必须做点什么来打破这个循环。所以我决定签署一份合同，让我成为正式租户，而不是非法的二房东。我甚至不确定自己是否想住在一间我已经住了90%时间都极其不快乐的公寓里，我大部分时间都在焦虑：A，我是否会留下；B，我是否会开始写小说或开始我的劳伦斯研究。但当代理商说他们不愿把房子租给我这个没有工作、没有稳定收入的外国人时，我变得确信我必须留在这个我其实一直非常快乐的公寓里。事实上，在这个世界上，我不可能希望在别处过得更好了。最终，我那有钱的朋友埃尔韦·兰德里（Herve Landry），我喜欢叫他“钱财兰德里”，同意做我的担保人。
The managing agents relented, and I signed the lease that made me the official locataire. I was ecstatic for about five minutes. Then I realized I'd taken on an awesome, not to say, crippling responsibility. And far from solving the problem of where to live, I'd actually put a lid on it, so that now my uncertainty was boiling away under pressure, threatening to blow me apart. The one thing I could be sure of was that I had to leave this apartment where I'd never known a moment's peace of mind as soon as possible. If I stayed here, I saw now, I would fail to write both my novel and my study of Lawrence. That much was obvious.
代理商妥协了，我签署了租约，成为正式承租人。我兴奋了大约五分钟。然后我意识到我承担了一项可怕的、甚至是令人崩溃的责任。我不仅没有解决住在哪里这个问题，反而给它加了个盖子，现在我的不确定性在压力下沸腾，威胁着要让我崩溃。我可以确定的一件事是，我必须尽快离开这个让我从未有过片刻安宁的公寓。我现在明白了，如果我留在这里，我既写不成小说，也写不成关于劳伦斯的研究。这一点很明显。
Round and round I went, making no progress, resolving one thing one moment and another the next. I wrote to the agents and officially renounced the flat, claiming that "professional reasons" had obliged me to return to England. The agents wrote back, acknowledging my decision to leave the apartment. I wrote back, saying that, "Professional reasons now oblige me to remain in Paris. Could I, therefore, unrenounce my apartment?" Relieved to be free of the trouble of re-letting it, the agents agreed to let me remain in the apartment, which I had just renounced.
我转来转去，毫无进展，一会儿决定这样，一会儿决定那样。我写信给代理商正式退租，声称“专业原因”迫使我回到英国。代理商回信，确认了我离开公寓的决定。我回信说：“专业原因现在迫使我留在巴黎。因此，我能撤回退租申请吗？”代理商为了省去重新招租的麻烦，同意让我继续留在刚刚被我退掉的公寓里。
And so it went on. I wrote again to renounce the apartment definitively. They sent a somewhat curt acknowledgement of my decision. I wrote back, changing my definitive decision to leave to a definitive decision to stay. But it was too late. I had to leave.
事情就这样继续下去。我又写信明确退租。他们发来了一封语气有些生硬的确认函。我回信说，我把离开的最终决定改为了留下的最终决定。但已经太晚了。我必须离开。
Now that I did have to leave, I was faced with the terrible prospect of having nowhere to live, of having to decide where to live without delay. And only then did I realize how much this apartment meant to me, how it had actually become my home. Although I believed that I'd hardly any of my things in this apartment, there were actually many of my own things that I now had to find a place for.
现在我真的必须离开了，我面临着一个可怕的前景：无处可去，必须立即决定住在哪里。也就在那时，我才意识到这个公寓对我意味着什么，它实际上已经成了我的家。虽然我认为公寓里几乎没有什么我的东西，但实际上我有很多个人物品，现在必须找到地方安放。
Over the years, I'd actually acquired quite a few of the trappings of permanence. I even owned a surprising amount of furniture, some of it rather nice. Where was I going to store it? And what about me? Where was I going to store myself?
多年来，我实际上获取了不少永恒的附属品。我甚至拥有数量惊人的家具，其中一些还相当不错。我该把它们存放在哪儿？还有我呢？我该把自己存放在哪儿？
Rome was a possibility. Laura, my almost-wife, had a lovely apartment in Rome and was always arguing in favor of our settling there. I fretted and wondered. Why was I even prevaricating like this? I was mad not to go to Rome. Rome was in Italy, the country where the Lawrences had spent more time than any other. If I was to stand any chance of making any progress with my study of Lawrence, it was probably the very best place I could be.
罗马是一个选择。劳拉，我那几乎算作妻子的爱人，在罗马有一间可爱的公寓，总是主张我们在那里定居。我焦虑着，纠结着。为什么我甚至要这样推托呢？我不去罗马简直是疯了。罗马在意大利，这是劳伦斯夫妇花费时间最多的国家。如果我想要在劳伦斯研究上取得任何进展，那很可能是我所能待的最好的地方。
As soon as I arrived, I knew I'd made the right decision. My mind was made up. I was ready to begin my study of D.H. Lawrence. The only trouble was the heat. The heat was tremendous. And nowhere in Rome was hotter than Laura's apartment.
我一到那里，就知道我做了正确的决定。我已经下定决心。我准备开始我的D.H.劳伦斯研究了。唯一的麻烦是天气。天气热得要命。而在罗马，没有任何地方比劳拉的公寓更热。
Even the light was hot. We tried to keep the light at bay, but it drilled through the keyhole, squeezed under the door, levered open the smallest of cracks in the shutters. My mind was made up. I was ready to work. But it was too hot to work. It was so hot, we spent our waking hours dozing and our sleeping hours lying awake, trying to sleep. We were in a kind of trance.
连光线都带着热度。我们试图阻挡光线，但它从锁孔钻入，从门缝挤进，撬开百叶窗最细小的缝隙。我下定决心。我准备好工作了。但实在太热，没法工作。天气太热了，我们醒着的时候都在打盹，睡着的时候却躺着清醒，试图入睡。我们处于一种恍惚状态。
The perfect life, the perfect lie, is one which prevents you from doing that which you would ideally have done, painted, say, or written unpublishable poetry, but which, in fact, you've no wish to do. People need to feel that they've been thwarted by circumstances from pursuing the life which, had they led it, they would not have wanted. Whereas the life they really want is precisely a compound of all those thwarting circumstances. It's a very elaborate, extremely simple procedure, arranging this web of self-deceit, contriving to convince yourself that you were prevented from doing what you wanted.
完美的生活，完美的谎言，就是那种阻止你做你本可以做到的事情（比如画画，或者写些无法出版的诗歌），但事实上你根本没有愿望去做的事情。人们需要感到自己因为环境阻碍而无法追求某种生活，如果真的过上了那种生活，他们反而不会想要。而他们真正想要的生活，恰恰是所有那些阻碍因素的集合。这是一个非常复杂却又极其简单的程序，编织起这种自欺欺人的网，让自己确信是外界阻止了你做你想做的事。
Most people don't want what they want. People want to be prevented, restricted. The hamster not only loves his cage, he'd be lost without it.
大多数人并不想要他们声称想要的东西。人们想要的是被阻止、被限制。仓鼠不仅爱它的笼子，没有笼子它反而会迷失。
That's why children are so convenient. You have children because you're struggling to get by as an artist or failing to get on with your career. Then you can persuade yourself that your children prevented you from having this career that never looked like working out. And so it goes on. Things are always forsaken in the name of an obligation to someone else, never as a failing, a falling short of yourself.
这就是为什么孩子这么方便。你生孩子是因为你作为艺术家在挣扎，或者事业不顺。然后你可以说服自己是孩子阻止了你实现那个本来就没什么希望的事业。事情总是以对他人的义务为名而被抛弃，而不是因为自己的失败或不足。
I've devoted more of my life to thoughts of giving up than anyone else I can think of. Nietzsche wrote that the thought of suicide had got him through many a bad night. And thinking of giving up is probably the one thing that's kept me going. I think about it on a daily basis, but always come up against the problem of what to do when I've given up. Give up one thing, and you're immediately obliged to do something else.
我一生中在“放弃”这个念头上花费的时间，比我能想到的任何人都多。尼采写道，自杀的念头让他度过了许多糟糕的夜晚。而考虑放弃可能是我坚持下去的唯一动力。我每天都会想这件事，但总是面临“放弃之后做什么”的问题。放弃了一件事，你立即就得做另一件事。
Let's suppose, for example, that I decided to call it a day, to give up, to abandon any attempt not just at earning a living, but having a life. But what then? What would happen next? Within five minutes, I'd be thinking about listening to music and would put a CD on the stereo. Five minutes after that, I'd be up again because I would have grown fed up with that piece of music and would be scanning the shelves and shelves of CDs, searching in vain for a piece of music that I was not heartily sick of, thinking to myself that if I had more CDs, there would surely be one that I would like to listen to. And before I knew it, I'd be out of the house and on my way to the megastore, looking for a new CD.
举个例子，假设我决定收手、放弃、停止一切努力，不仅是不再为了谋生，甚至不再为了生活。那然后呢？接下来会发生什么？五分钟内，我就会想听音乐，把CD放进音响。再过五分钟，我就又会站起来，因为我对那段音乐厌倦了，开始扫描架子上的一排排CD，徒劳地寻找一张我不感到极其厌恶的音乐，心想如果我有多一点CD，肯定会有我喜欢听的。没过多久，我就已经出门去超级商店买新CD了。
Should anyone flatter us by asking what we're looking for, what we are searching for, then we think immediately, almost instinctively in vast terms. God, fulfillment, love. But our lives are actually made up of lots of tiny searches for things like a CD we are not sick of, an out-of-print edition of Phoenix, a picture of Lawrence that I saw when I was 17, another identical pair of suede shoes to the ones that I'm wearing now. Add them together, and these little things make up an epic quest, more than enough for one lifetime.
如果有人奉承我们，问我们在寻找什么，我们在追求什么，我们会立刻、近乎本能地从宏大的角度去思考。上帝，成就感，爱。但我们的生活实际上是由许多小小的搜寻组成的，比如一张我们不厌倦的CD，一本绝版的《凤凰》，一张我17岁时见过的劳伦斯照片，或者一双跟我现在穿的一模一样的麂皮鞋。把这些加在一起，这些小事构成了一场史诗般的探索，足以填满一生。
Thinking specifically of the search for CDs, let's assume that after deciding to give up, after sitting around listening to CDs and going out to buy a new CD, I found a CD I liked the idea of listening to. Still, at some point, I would not simply grow tired of listening to this new CD, but would actually become heartily sick of the idea of listening to CDs and would think to myself that sitting around listening to CDs is a much more enjoyable activity, a much more enjoyable inactivity if it is a relief from something else, anything else. And so I would resign myself to picking up my pen and trying once again if for no other reason than to render listening to my CDs a little less dispiriting, to make some progress with my study of D.H. Lawrence.
特别想到寻找CD这件事，假设在我决定放弃之后，在坐着听CD和出门买新CD之后，我找到了一张我想听的CD。即便如此，在某个时刻，我不仅会对听这张新CD感到厌倦，而且会真正厌倦“听CD”这个想法，心想坐着听CD是一种更令人愉快的活动——如果它是一种解脱的话，从其他任何事情中解脱出来。所以我不得不拿起笔再次尝试，哪怕只是为了让听音乐变得不那么令人沮丧，以便在我的D.H.劳伦斯研究上取得一点进展。
And there you have it. One way or another, we all have to write our studies of D.H. Lawrence even if they will never be published, even if we will never complete them, even if all we are left with after years and years of effort is an unfinished, unfinishable record of how we failed to live up to our own earlier ambitions. Still, we all have to try to make some progress with our books about D.H. Lawrence. The world over, from Taos to Taormina, from the places we have visited to countries we will never set foot in, the best we can do is to try to make some progress with our studies of D.H. Lawrence.
就是这样。不管怎样，我们每个人都必须写我们的D.H.劳伦斯研究，即使它们永远不会出版，即使我们永远完成不了，即使经过多年的努力，我们留下的只是一份未完成的、无法完成的记录——记录我们如何辜负了自己早期的雄心。即便如此，我们每个人都必须努力在关于D.H.劳伦斯的书上取得一些进展。全世界，从陶斯到陶尔米纳，从我们去过的地方到我们永远不会涉足的国家，我们能做的最好的事，就是努力在我们的D.H.劳伦斯研究上取得一点进展。
Geoff Dyer reading an excerpt from his amazing, little book Out of Sheer Rage. He's also the author of Paris Trance and But Beautiful, a book about jazz.
刚才杰夫·戴尔朗读了他那本精彩的小书《纯粹愤怒之外》（Out of Sheer Rage）的节选。他还是《巴黎恍惚》（Paris Trance）和关于爵士乐的书《依然美丽》（But Beautiful）的作者。
[MUSIC - "WHEN I WRITE THE BOOK" BY NICK LOWE]
[音乐 - 尼克·洛（Nick Lowe）演唱的《当我写那本书时》]
Act Two, Dance. What do we do when we're not doing something? Not writing a book, not doing our jobs, not falling in love. Sometimes, we just feel self-conscious. Sometimes, we spend a lot of time explaining ourselves. And sometimes both. We have this from Danny Hoch. As he tells this story on stage, he limps back and forth across the stage on a cane of some kind.
第二幕，《舞蹈》。当我们不做某事时，我们都在做什么？不写书、不做工作、不坠入爱河。有时，我们只是感到局促不安。有时，我们花很多时间来解释自己。有时两者兼有。这段来自丹尼·霍克。他在舞台上讲述这个故事时，拄着一根拐杖一瘸一拐地走来走去。
Hi. How you doing? Excuse me. So nice to meet you. So what's your name? My name's Victor. Right? Nice to meet you.
嗨。你好吗？不好意思。很高兴见到你。你叫什么名字？我叫维克多。对吧？很高兴见到你。
So you come here often? Ha-ha, I didn't think so, right? So what you doing here? Wait, let me guess, let me guess. You're visiting your grandfather, right? I was close though, right? Is she sick? Oh, I'm sorry.
你常来这儿吗？哈哈，我想也是，对吧？你在这儿干嘛呢？等等，让我猜猜。你是在探望你爷爷，对吧？我猜得差不多吧？她生病了吗？噢，我很抱歉。
So you know I'm not here all the time. Nah, I just have to see the doctors like this week and next week because I have sort of like complications. Not really like complications. But like somebody shot me two years ago. It's complicated. Ha-ha. Don't worry. You didn't shoot me, right?
你知道我不常来这儿。没，我只是这周和下周得见医生，因为我有某种并发症。也不完全是并发症，就是两年前有人开枪打了我。很复杂。哈哈。别担心。不是你开枪打的我，对吧？
So so you're very pretty. Know that? So you live around here? You sure? I'm saying 'cause I seen this really pretty girl on 149th Street. I thought maybe that was you. But that wasn't you? You sure? I'm just making sure. Ha ha.
你真漂亮。知道吗？你就住这附近吗？确定？因为我在149街见过一个很漂亮的女孩，我以为那可能是你。但那不是你？你确定？我只是确认一下。哈哈。
So you want me to talk to the guard to see if they'll let you upstairs quicker? Nah, 'cause like they make you wait a really long time just to visit somebody. It doesn't matter how sick that they are. And if you want, I can ax them because like, you know, I know him. 'Cause like he's a friend of mine 'cause like I have to come here like every week. So like, you know, we kind of know each other.
你想让我去跟警卫说一声，让他们快点让你上楼吗？没，因为他们总是让你等很久才能探望病人。不管病得有多重。如果你想，我可以去问他们，因为你知道，我认识他。因为他是我的朋友，我每周都得来这儿。所以，你知道，我们算认识吧。
I mean, I don't have to come here like every week. But, you know, like every now and then, I come here for like rehabilitation. I mean, not rehabilitation like I'm a drug addict or some [BLEEP] like that, but, you know, for like therapy. I mean, not therapy like I'm crazy or some [BLEEP] like that. But, you know, for like physical therapy.
我是说，我不必每周都来这儿。但你知道，偶尔我来这儿做康复。我是说，不是那种吸毒者的康复，而是，你知道，物理治疗。我是说，不是那种疯子的治疗，而是物理治疗。
Oh, nah, I can't really talk about it. I can't really discuss it 'cause like I can't get into it. Nah, I can't really mention it. Because like my mother, she doesn't like me to talk about it 'cause like it's just, you know, it's not cool.
噢，不，我不能真的谈论它。我不能真的讨论它，因为我不能细说。不，我不能提它。因为我母亲不喜欢我谈论这件事，因为它，你知道，不怎么好。
I mean, I mean, not like I do everything my mother tells me to do. I'll do what I want, you know, but. Nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, ha-ha, ha, nah, nah. Ha, ha-ha, nah, ha.
我是说，不是那种我妈让我干什么我就干什么。我会做我想做的事，你知道，但是。不，不，不，哈哈，不。哈哈，不。
Aight, aight, aight, aight, aight, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah, aight, aight, aight, aight, nah, aight. Like, it was two years ago, and I was outside my house. And my friends that came by, and they asked me if I want to go for a ride, right?
好吧，好吧，好吧，不，不。事情是这样的，那是两年前，我在我家外面。我朋友开车过来，问我要不要去兜风，对吧？
But like I didn't know the car was stolen. I mean, I thought it might have been, but, like, I wasn't sure. I mean, like, my friend, like, he could have bought it, but he didn't, right? And like, in one block, the cops stopped us, and they made us get out.
但我不知道车是偷来的。我是说，我以为可能是，但，我不确定。我朋友可能会买下来，但他没买，对吧？在一个街区后，警察拦下了我们，让我们下车。
And then, like, I don't know what happened. I guess, like, my friend had moved or something. I mean, you have to move when you get out the car, right? But I guess, like, this one cop had panicked 'cause like he thought that my friend had a gun or whatever. So he, like, just started, like, shooting or whatever.
然后，不知道发生了什么。我猜，我朋友可能动了一下或者什么。你下车肯定得动，对吧？但我猜，那个警察慌了，他以为我朋友有枪还是什么的。所以他就开始，开枪了。
But like I told you, I can't really talk about. I can't discuss it 'cause, like, if my mother-- it's not right. I can't be talking, you know, about this situation. But I mean, that said, it was an accident.
但就像我告诉你的，我不能谈论这个。我不能讨论，因为如果我妈——这不对。我不能谈论这种情况。但我说真的，那是个意外。
No, like, I was really in the New York Post. And they were talking about, like, 12 different reasons why it could have been an accident. No, I mean, I was there. I got shot. I'm not saying that. But I'm saying, like, the more I read about it, the more I think it might have been an accident.
不，我真的上过《纽约邮报》。他们谈论了12种可能导致意外的原因。不，我是说，当时我在场。我中枪了，我不是那个意思。我是说，我读的越多，越觉得那可能是一场意外。
But man, you got a nice smile. Where you live at? Staten Island? That's far.
老兄，你笑起来真好看。你住哪儿？史坦顿岛？那太远了。
But you speak Spanish though, right? You're Dominican? But you're Dominican though, right? You're Dominican. You're Dominican. You're Dominican. I know you're Dominican.
但你会说西班牙语，对吧？你是多米尼加人？但你是多米尼加人对吧？你是多米尼加人。我知道你是多米尼加人。
Czechoslovakia? Damn. I'm kinda off, right? For real? Nah, I thought she was Dominican.
捷克斯洛伐克？该死。我猜错了吧？真的？我以为她是多米尼加人。
So Czechoslovakia. Where's that at? That's, like, near Germany, right? I'm close though, right? Nah, I know it's like, it's right in that area.
捷克斯洛伐克。那在哪儿？就在德国附近，对吧？我猜得差不多吧？我知道，就在那个区域。
Matter of fact, I think it, like, borders it because I look at maps a lot, like, in my room at home. I just kinda like-- I have maps up in the walls and everything. Nah, just, like, to look at different places or whatever.
事实上，我觉得它和德国接壤，因为我在家房间里常看地图。我只是，你知道，墙上挂着地图之类的。只是看看不同的地方。
So what they eat over there? Like, cheese? Oh, you never been there? Oh, my bad. Oh, your parents? Oh, my bad. My bad.
他们那儿吃什么？奶酪吗？噢，你从来没去过？抱歉。那是你父母？抱歉，抱歉。
So you go to school? I could tell. I'm saying. 'Cause you got that look. I'm not saying you look stupid, like a nerd or something like that. I'm saying, like, you look smart.
你上学吗？我看得出来。我是说，你有那个样子。我不是说你看起来笨，像书呆子那样。我是说，你看起来很聪明。
Like, you definitely got plans for your future or whatever. Like, you know, mission or something. What you study? Oh, that's good. We need more business people, right? Ah ha ha.
你肯定对未来有规划什么的。像是什么使命。你学什么？噢，那很好。我们需要更多商务人才，对吧？哈哈哈。
Like, me, personally, I would like to go into the Air Force if they let me. I heard it's still possible, right? Nah, 'cause I would like to protect this country. From like whoever. From evil dictators, or like from Saddam Hussein, or Fidel Castro, or whoever.
像我个人，如果他们让我进的话，我想去空军。我听说还是可能的，对吧？我想保卫这个国家。对抗什么之类的。对抗独裁者，或者萨达姆·侯赛因，或者菲德尔·卡斯特罗，或者任何人。
Nah, 'cause you don't realize. I'm not saying you. But, like, it's people out there. They don't realize, like, this is the greatest country in the world. And, like, other places, you don't know what could happen. Like, people could just be savages or whatever.
你没意识到。我不是说你。但外面有很多人不明白，这是世界上最伟大的国家。在其他地方，你不知道会发生什么。人们可能是野蛮人之类的。
Like, the government, they just, like, shoot you for whatever reason. But at least here, you know, we have democracy. Everybody's protected. But mostly, I would like to fly, like, a F-15 or a stealth bomber. Because I would just kind of like to like fly over all the different places in the maps.
政府可能随便找个理由就开枪打你。但在这里，我们有民主。每个人都受到保护。但我最想驾驶F-15或隐形轰炸机。因为我特别想飞过地图上的那些地方。
Nah, I wouldn't really start nowhere. I would just kind of  like fly over, look at it, maybe drop a few bombs, or whatever. Nah, I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I mean, not really but.
我不会真的从哪儿开始。我只是想飞过，看看，也许扔几枚炸弹之类的。我在开玩笑。我在开玩笑。我是说，也不是完全开玩笑。
Man, they make you wait a long time. See? I told you. So you sure you don't want me to talk to him? It's not a problem.
老兄，他们让你等得真久。看？我告诉过你。你确定不想让我去说说吗？那不是问题。
I mean, like, it's messed up. Your grandmother got cancer and everything. You know, they shouldn't make you wait down here for, like, four hours. Are you sure? Alright. I'm just making sure.
这太糟糕了。你祖母得了癌症之类的。他们不该让你在这儿等四个小时。你确定？好吧。我只是确认一下。
So would you like to go out with me some time? I'm saying, you know, I'm not Tom Cruise or nothing, but I'm Puerto Rican. You know what they say about Puerto Ricans, right? You didn't watching The Discovery Channel entertainment special? Nah, they did a whole report. They discovered us.
你想什么时候和我出去吗？我是说，我也不是汤姆·克鲁斯，但我波多黎各人。你知道他们怎么说波多黎各人吗？你没看探索频道的特别节目吗？他们做了一个完整报道。他们发现了我们。
They said that Puerto Ricans are the best dancers in the world. I mean, like, they didn't say it. But, like, that's what they were saying.
他们说波多黎各人是世界上最好的舞者。我是说，他们没说出口。但，那大概就是他们的意思。
I bet you like to go to the clubs dancing, right? What you dance to? Oh, yeah? That's it? Nah, I go almost every weekend. Like, and my friends take me. I dance to whatever, merengue, salsa, hip-hop, classical.
我打赌你肯定喜欢去夜店跳舞，对吧？你跳什么舞？噢，是吗？就这样？我几乎每个周末都去。我朋友带我去。我什么都跳，梅伦格舞、萨尔萨舞、嘻哈、古典舞。
Nah, like, even like grunge. I don't even think people can dance to grunge, but I could do it. You don't think I can dance, right? Nah, I been practicing for the last two years. And plus, they said on The Discovery Channel, it doesn't matter as long as you're Puerto Rican.
连垃圾摇滚我也跳。我觉得人们可能觉得跳不了垃圾摇滚，但我能跳。你觉得我不能跳，对吧？我已经练了两年了。而且，探索频道说，只要你是波多黎各人，跳什么都无所谓。
You don't think I can dance, right? Girl, you and me could practice right here. There's nobody looking. There's nobody looking though. Oh, all right.
你觉得我跳不了，对吧？女孩，你跟我可以在这儿练。没人看着。真的没人看着。噢，好吧。
No, that's all right. I understand, understand. Nah, it's all right. I understand, understand, understand.
不，没关系。我理解，理解。不，没关系。我理解，理解，理解。
Well, tell her I hope she feels better, all right? All right. Um, nice meeting you. All right. Bye.
好吧，帮我转告她，祝她早日康复，好吗？好的。见到你很高兴。再见。
It's the fourth floor. Push the button. You're very pretty. Man, I thought she was Dominican, word.
在四楼。按那个按钮。你真漂亮。天哪，我以为她是多米尼加人，真的。
Danny Hoch. That series from his one-man show, Jails, Hospitals and Hip-Hop. CDs of his show are available at his website, www.dannyhoch--with an H--.com. Coming up, making a deal with the prosecutor means 25 years in prison and not making the deal means 75 years. Why you might say no to the 25 years. And other stories of what we do when we don't do something. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
丹尼·霍克。这是他单人秀《监狱、医院和嘻哈》中的片段。他的演出CD可在其网站购买，网址是www.dannyhoch--带H--.com。接下来，和检察官达成交易意味着25年监禁，而不达成交易则意味着75年。为什么你会拒绝25年的交易。以及关于我们不做某事时所做的其他故事。一分钟后，国际公共广播电台的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, We Didn't. Stories of what it is that we do when we're not doing all of the things that we think of as our actual lives. We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Same Time Next Year. This is the story of a couple that did not fall in love, did not get together, did not form a future, and some other stuff that'll be clear as this story unfolds.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的各种故事。今天的节目是《我们没做》。关于我们不做那些被认为是真实生活的琐事时，我们都在做什么的故事。我们已经进入节目的第三幕。第三幕，《明年此时》。这是一个关于一对情侣没有坠入爱河，没有在一起，没有形成未来的故事，以及一些随着故事展开会变得清楚的事情。
It all begins simply enough when Amanda Marks is 13, going on 14, and she goes to Madison Square Garden to buy tickets to the Rolling Stones' Tattoo You tour in the early '80s. And she stands in line next to a cute 21-year-old for three hours. And they get to talking and talking some more.
这一切始于阿曼达·马克斯（Amanda Marks）13岁快14岁时，她在80年代初去麦迪逊广场花园买滚石乐队“纹身你”（Tattoo You）巡演的门票。她在一个可爱的21岁男孩旁边排了三个小时的队。他们开始聊天，聊得投机。
So we go and get our tickets. And the way they did the system was it was completely randomized. And so he was right behind me in line, or right in front of me, but I ended up getting much better seats than he did. So basically, we made this deal that we would go to the concert together, and sell his pair, and split the money.
我们去买了票。那个系统是完全随机分配的。他就在我前面排队，但我拿到的座位比他好得多。所以我们做了一个交易，我们一起去看演唱会，卖掉他的两张票，平分钱。
Do you remember what exactly was attracting you to him?
你还记得是什么吸引了你吗？
I was a teenage girl. And he was this really cute guy paying attention to me. What wouldn't have been attractive about him?
我是个十几岁的女孩。他是个很可爱的家伙，又关注我。还有什么比这更吸引人的呢？
So it's raining. We share a cab uptown. I'm going back to school. I've taken the morning off. I'm trying to catch my English class. And we start kissing in the back of the taxi. And the rain's hammering down. And it's just-- it's like the movies. It just couldn't be more romantic. I'm feeling so grown up at this point, just thrilled.
当时在下雨。我们合乘一辆出租车去上城。我要回学校。我请了上午的假。我想赶去上英语课。我们在出租车后座开始接吻。大雨倾盆。这就像电影一样。简直不能更浪漫了。我当时觉得自己很成熟，非常兴奋。
So I go back to school, and I'm all excited. And I tell my friends. And one of my friends gives me this look like, "He's how old? He does what? He's an out-of-work actor? Like, ew." And I was like, "No, no, he's really great."
我回到学校，非常激动。我告诉了朋友们。其中一个朋友用那种眼神看着我，仿佛在说：“他多大？他干什么的？失业演员？好恶心。”我说：“不，不，他真的很棒。”
I love how he's an out-of-work actor is a turnoff even if you're 13. Even if you're in junior high school, it just doesn't play.
我喜欢这种即使你13岁也觉得“失业演员”很扫兴的感觉。即使你在读初中，这个身份也吃不开。
Like, oh, yeah, out-of-work actor. Out of here.
就像，哦，是的，失业演员。滚开吧。
So your friends are skeptical.
所以你的朋友们很怀疑。
Yes. Yes, they are. And it was weird because I wouldn't go to his house. I didn't really want him coming to my house. So we'd meet in public places, have these long, intense, involved conversations.
是的。是的，他们很怀疑。奇怪的是我不想去他家。我也不想他来我家。所以我们在公共场合见面，进行那些漫长、激烈、投入的对话。
Instead of making out.
代替了做爱。
Yeah, basically. Yeah.
是的，基本上。是的。
Taking the place of, using the energy that could be devoted to--
代替了，利用本来可以投入到——的能量。
Well, but I was very serious. I was very excited that he liked me for my mind, that we had this connection, that it wasn't about that. But finally, the sexual side got a little sticky. And my last encounter with him was just uncomfortable. The fact was he was 21. I was 14. I wasn't going to go to his house alone. And that was pretty much a deal breaker.
嗯，我当时很认真。我很兴奋他喜欢我的头脑，我们有这种联系，而不是因为那些。但最终，身体层面变得有点尴尬。我和他的最后一次接触真的很不舒服。事实是他21岁。我14岁。我不会单独去他家。那几乎是一个底线。
OK. It's about 12 years later. I'm back in New York City for some family stuff. I'm wandering through Central Park. I don't really have anything to do that night. And suddenly, I get this flash.
好。大约12年后。我为了家里的事回到纽约。我在中央公园闲逛。那天晚上我没什么事可做。突然，我产生了一种预感。
I'm like, it's summer. It's about 5 o'clock. Shakespeare in the Park. So I wander over to the Delacorte.
我想，是夏天。大约5点钟。公园莎士比亚戏剧节。所以我漫步到了德拉科特（Delacorte）。
And there's just this endless, endless line. It's just huge. And I get all the way on the end of it. And it's clear to me that I'm not going to get in. And so I come up with this scheme to cut to the front of the line. So I go from the end to fourth.
那里排着无穷无尽的长队。太壮观了。我走到队尾。很明显我进不去了。所以我发明了一个计划，插队到前面。我从队尾跑到了第四个位置。
And I see this really, really, really cute guy pull the exact same line-cutting ploy that I did. The exact same thing. And he's really cute. And so I catch his eye. And I walk over, and I say, "You know, I did the exact same thing." And he goes, "Yeah, I don't know why anybody waits in line. I always do this. It's great."
然后我看到一个非常、非常、非常可爱的男孩用了和我一模一样的插队伎俩。完全一样。他很可爱。于是我跟他对视了一下，走过去说：“你知道吗，我也做了同样的事。”他说：“是啊，不知道为什么有人要排队。我总是这样。太棒了。”
So we start chatting. He's got a blanket. I've got some fruit.
我们开始聊天。他带着毯子。我带着些水果。
And we're chatting and eating away, perfectly comfortable conversation. He asked me my name. I tell him. He tells me his name. And then he tells me his last name. And I recognize it.
我们聊着天，吃着东西，对话非常舒服。他问我的名字。我告诉了他。他告诉了我他的名字。然后他说了他的姓。我认出来了。
I can't not recognize it. Because his name was always really uncomfortable for me. His name is a synonym for the male anatomy. But he pronounces it differently. And it just always made me really uncomfortable when I was 14.
我无法不认出来。因为他的姓总是让我感到很不舒服。他的姓是男性器官的同义词。但他发音不同。这让我14岁的时候总是感到非常尴尬。
I pause, and my heart starts pounding. My mouth dries up. And I say, "Over 12 years ago, you and I picked each other up in line for Rolling Stones tickets." And he stares at me.
我停顿了一下，心跳加速。嘴里发干。我说：“12年前，我们曾在滚石乐队排队买票时认识。”他盯着我。
And he totally knows who I am. His jaw drops. He completely remembers. He can't believe it. I can't believe it.
他完全知道我是谁。他下巴都掉了。他完全记得。他不敢相信。我也不敢相信。
And it's just so romantic. What could be more romantic? We're in Central Park. We're on a blanket. We're about to go see Shakespeare in the Park. It's like it's destiny.
这真是太浪漫了。还有什么比这更浪漫的呢？我们在中央公园。我们在毯子上。我们要去看公园莎士比亚戏剧了。这简直是宿命。
Oh my god, and the play? All's Well That Ends Well.
哦天哪，剧名呢？《皆大欢喜》（All's Well That Ends Well）。
So it's all symbolic. It's all coming together. It's all magical. And all forming around one thought.
所以这全是象征性的。一切都汇聚在一起。一切都很神奇。而且都是围绕一个念头形成的。
Oh, it just could not be more perfect. I'm thinking, this is the story you tell the grandchildren. I love romantic comedies. I write romantic comedies. It's just like this is what happens in the movies. I'm so excited.
哦，简直不能更完美了。我想，这就是讲给孙子孙女听的故事。我喜欢浪漫喜剧。我写浪漫喜剧。电影里就是这样演的。我太激动了。
And we see the play. And we leave, and we walk back to his place. And then the sleaze factor of this 21-year-old who dated this 14-year-old starts to rear its head. What was this guy doing dating me when I was 14? That's not acceptable.
我们看了戏。然后离开，走回他的住处。然后那个曾经约会过14岁少女的21岁男人的猥琐就开始显露出来了。这个家伙在跟我交往时到底在干什么？这不被接受。
The tip-offs, there were just so many little things. We go back to his apartment. His apartment was really this mess. Oh, it seemed like he was kind of a pot head. He was smoking out the whole time. He was growing weed on his balcony. He was constantly smoking out.
暗示，有很多小细节。我们回了他的公寓。他的公寓简直是个猪圈。噢，他好像是个大麻瘾君子。他一直在吸大麻。他在阳台上种大麻。他一直在抽。
Was he still an out-of-work actor?
他还是一名失业演员吗？
Yeah. He hadn't really done much with himself.
是啊。他没做出什么成就。
That's interesting because when there's that kind of coincidence of running into somebody again, we think automatically that it should turn out to be romantic. But it could be that you just meet some people again, just have exactly the same experience over again.
这很有意思，因为当这种巧合发生再次遇到某人时，我们自动认为那应该是浪漫的。但可能你只是再次遇到了某些人，拥有完全一样的体验。
Yeah, yeah. In case you didn't learn that lesson once. So it just got yuckier. I left eventually. And he would call me randomly, drunk, at 11:30 at night, from some bar, like, "What are you doing?"
是啊，是啊。以防你上次没学会教训。事情变得越来越恶心。我最终离开了。他会随机地在半夜11:30喝醉了给我打电话，在酒吧里说：“你在干嘛？”
And so this whole thing stayed in the "We didn't" stage. You just never went forward out of "We didn't." It was sort of like you were reunited to re-experience the "We didn't."
所以这一切都停留在“我们没做”的阶段。你从未从“我们没做”阶段向前迈进。就像你们重聚只是为了重温“我们没做”的体验。
Yeah. At first, it seemed like there was this big cosmic thing keeping us apart, age. There's so few things to actually keep couples apart anymore. You know what I mean? I write romantic comedies, and it's really hard to come up with a reason that people don't just jump into bed in the first 20 minutes.
是啊。起初，似乎有一种宏大的宇宙力量让我们分开，年龄。现在几乎没有什么能真正阻碍情侣了。你知道我的意思吗？我写浪漫喜剧，真的很难找到一个理由，让人们不在前20分钟就滚床单。
Oh, come. Are you serious?
噢，真的吗？你是认真的？
Yeah, it's hard. Sure. When you're doing the whole "It's kismet, and we know that they're meant to be," yeah, sure, that's hard to sustain dramatically. That's why most romantic comedies are so boring and predictable.
是啊，很难。当然。当你表现出“这就是宿命，注定在一起”的时候，那很难在戏剧性上维持。这就是为什么大多数浪漫喜剧如此无聊和可预测。
Because there's not enough keeping them apart.
因为没有足够的阻碍让它们分开。
It's like, oh, he's engaged to some other girl who's really stuck up and comes from this rich family. And we know that he's never going to end up with this stuck-up girl. Do you know what I mean? But they go through the motions of he has to figure it out that she's not right for him. And you know I mean? That's why most romantic comedies are so middling and why it's really hard to make a good one.
比如，哦，他跟另一个爱摆架子的富家女订婚了。我们知道他永远不会和那个爱摆架子的女孩在一起。你知道我的意思吗？但他们必须走过场，他必须意识到她不适合自己。你知道我的意思吗？这就是为什么大多数浪漫喜剧都平庸至极，为什么很难拍出一部好的。
So we had that. We had age. It was pretty dramatic. It was very real then.
所以我们有那个。我们有年龄问题。那当时非常有戏剧性。那时候很真实。
I'm surprised at what you're saying about romantic comedies.
我对你关于浪漫喜剧的评论感到惊讶。
But I guess what I mean when I say it's hard now, compared to the heyday of Hollywood-- when you think of the classic romantic comedies, those were written under the Hays code. And you could not have two people going to bed together unless they were married. And so it was an obstacle in that very direct, obvious way. And you needed parent approval, and you needed to be of the same class, and all of that.
但我猜我说“现在很难”的意思是，相比好莱坞的黄金时代——当你想到经典的浪漫喜剧时，那是根据《海斯法典》（Hays code）编写的。在结婚之前，你不能让两个人上床。所以那是一个非常直接、明显的障碍。你需要家长的许可，你需要门当户对等等。
And now, with sexual mores so changed, that's really the thing. It's like, well, what's stopping these two people from going to bed?
而现在，性道德已经改变，问题就在于：究竟是什么在阻止这两个人上床？
But what you're saying somehow is that we, as a people, spend less time in the realm of "We didn't" than we used to two generations ago.
但你刚才的意思似乎是，与两代人前相比，我们现在在“我们没做”这个境界花费的时间更少了。
Yeah, I think now we spend time in "I wish we didn't," "I wish we hadn't."
是的，我想现在我们花时间在“我希望我们没做”、“我希望我们没发生过”的状态。
In other words, people actually get involved, but then regret it.
换句话说，人们实际上参与其中，但后来又后悔了。
Yeah, sure. That's really the story now.
是啊，当然。那才是现在的故事。
Amanda Marks, a screenwriter in Los Angeles.
阿曼达·马克斯，洛杉矶编剧。
[MUSIC - "'TIL THE NEXT GOODBYE" BY THE ROLLING STONES]
[音乐 - 滚石乐队的《直到下一次告别》]
Act Four, Saying No For 75 Years. For most of us, the stakes of not doing something on any given day are so low that as soon as the moment of decision passes, we never think of it again. It doesn't even linger as a memory. But sometimes, the stakes are so staggeringly high that we spend the rest of our lives in the shadow of that one decision, of one no. No, said at exactly the wrong moment to exactly the wrong person. Steve Bogira is a journalist who stumbled onto a story exactly like that about a guy named Vincent Bogan.
第四幕，《拒绝了75年》。对于大多数人来说，在任何一天不做某事的风险都很小，一旦决定的时刻过去，我们就再也不会想起它了。它甚至不会作为记忆残留。但有时，风险大得惊人，以至于我们要余生都生活在那一个决定、那一个“不”的阴影下。那是一个在极其错误的时刻对极其错误的人说出的“不”。史蒂夫·博吉拉（Steve Bogira）是一位偶然发现了一个类似故事的记者，主人公名叫文森特·博根（Vincent Bogan）。
I met Vincent 18 years ago when he was 15, when he was about to become a freshman at Bogan High School. Bogan is just a coincidence. It's the same as his name. Bogan is a high school on Chicago's Southwest side.
18年前，我在他15岁时认识了他，那时他即将成为博根高中的新生。博根只是个巧合。它和他名字一样。博根是芝加哥南区的一所高中。
At the time, it was all white, and Vincent was going to be one of the first black kids to go to this school. And I wanted to write a story for the Chicago Reader about what it'd be like for a black kid to come to that high school. So I rode the bus with him one September day in 1981 and followed him during his first day at Bogan.
当时，那所学校全是白人，而文森特将是第一批进入这所学校的黑人孩子之一。我想为《芝加哥读者报》（Chicago Reader）写一篇关于一个黑人孩子进入这所高中的故事。所以1981年9月的一天，我坐公交车陪他一起，跟踪了他第一天上学的经过。
What kind of kid was he at 15?
他在15岁时是个什么样的孩子？
The previous spring, he had been voted "Most Dedicated Student" in his eighth grade class, won $50 for that. He wanted to be an architect. And he was just a nice kid. He had a father who worked as a welder. His mother had been killed in a car accident a couple of years before. And he was the kind of kid who cuts the grass and sprinkles the lawn, wasn't the greatest student, but he did graduate.
前一个春天，他在八年级班里被选为“最敬业学生”，还赢了50美元奖金。他想成为一名建筑师。他是个很好的孩子。他有个父亲是一名焊工。他母亲几年前在一场车祸中丧生。他是个会帮着割草、浇草地的孩子，虽然学习成绩不是最顶尖的，但他确实毕业了。
So when did you hear of him next? How many years passed?
所以你后来怎么又听说他了？过了多少年？
I think it was in 1989. I saw a headline in the Tribune that caught my eye. It said something like, "An armed robber gets 75 years," which is a real long time for someone to do for armed robbery. And I read this story, and it said Vincent Bogan had been charged with 17 armed robberies committed in a six-week period in 1988.
我想是在1989年。我在《论坛报》（Tribune）上看到的一条标题引起了我的注意。标题写着类似“武装劫匪被判75年”的内容，对于武装抢劫来说，这是一段很长的刑期。我读了这个故事，说文森特·博根被指控在1988年的六周内犯下了17起武装抢劫案。
So I thought this is the Vincent who I wrote about. And I decided to find out what had happened.
所以我认为这就是我写过的那个文森特。我决定找出到底发生了什么。
What had happened, he found out, is that while Vincent was in high school, his father was laid off from his job as a welder and started dealing cocaine out of the house. He taught Vincent the family business. Not long after that, he died. Vincent became addicted to cocaine, stole to support his habit, and was caught. He was offered a deal by the state's attorney, a typical kind of deal for American courts today.
他发现，文森特在高中时，他父亲被焊工岗位裁员，开始在家里贩卖可卡因。他教文森特家族生意。没过多久，父亲就去世了。文森特染上了可卡因毒瘾，为了支持毒瘾而行窃，最终被捕。地方检察官给了他一个交易，这是今天美国法院里典型的交易方式。
If he would admit that he was guilty on all 17 counts of armed robbery, which would make a full trial unnecessary, there would be no trial, then he would get a 25-year sentence. This is called-- as anybody who watches cop shows on TV knows-- copping a plea, taking a plea bargain. And this is where Vincent said, no, said, no in a way that changed his life forever, said, no against the advice of everybody in his life. He wanted to go to trial.
如果他承认所有17项武装抢劫罪名成立，这样就不需要审判，没有庭审，他就能得到25年的刑期。这被称为——就像任何看电视警察剧的人都知道的那样——认罪辩诉，接受辩诉交易。这就是文森特说“不”的地方，他以一种永远改变他生命的方式说“不”，违背了他生命中所有人的建议说“不”。他想接受庭审。
His lawyer said it was a mistake. He tried to convince Vincent to take the deal, said, "Vincent, you're going to get hammered if you go to trial. You'll get much more than 25 years."
他的律师说那是个错误。他试图说服文森特接受交易，说：“文森特，如果你去庭审，你会惨败的。你会得到比25年多得多的刑期。”
He went to trial on 1 of the 17 counts of armed robbery. The judge gave him the maximum sentence, 30 years. He still had 16 counts left, 16 crimes.
他在17项武装抢劫罪名中的一项接受了审判。法官判了他最高刑期，30年。他还有16项指控，16宗犯罪。
At some point, it may have been just before sentencing, the state came to Vincent again and said, "Plead guilty to all the rest of these, and we'll give you just a total of 30." Vincent, again, said, "No, I want to go to trial." So he went to trial a second time, got found guilty again by a jury, and got sentenced to another 30.
在某个时刻，可能就在判刑之前，州政府再次找到文森特说：“承认剩下的所有罪名，我们就总共给你30年。”文森特再次说：“不，我想接受庭审。”所以他第二次接受了审判，再次被陪审团判定有罪，被判了另外30年。
After that, he went to trial again, got 15 years, bringing his total up to 75. Then he went to trial again, got 60 years. Though in one of those weird legal things that make very little sense to anybody outside of the court system, he serves the 60 at the same time as he serves the 75. Basically, the idea is that if he overturns one of his convictions, someday, on appeal, he still has to serve tons of time.
在那之后，他再次接受审判，得到了15年，使他的总刑期达到75年。然后他又接受审判，被判了60年。尽管在那些让法庭系统外的人难以理解的奇怪法律操作之一中，他可以同时服刑这60年和75年。基本上，想法是如果他将来上诉推翻其中一个定罪，他仍然要服大量的刑期。
This was an unusually long sentence for armed robbery. So much time that the state simply dropped the other 13 counts against him. Why bother? He'd be away 'til he was an old man.
对于武装抢劫来说，这是一个不同寻常的长刑期。时间太长了，以至于州政府干脆放弃了对他剩下的13项指控。何必费事呢？他要被关到老了。
The day the judge gave Vincent the second 30 years, he also sentenced another defendant in his courtroom for murdering two people to 60 years. This defendant had strangled one person with a telephone cord and stabbed the other person 21 times. He got the same 60 years that Vincent had at that point. The difference was the murderer pled guilty.
法官给文森特第二次30年的那天，他也给法庭里的另一名被告判了60年，那人谋杀了两个人。这名被告用电话线勒死了一个人，并刺了另一个人21刀。他得到了和文森特当时一样的60年。区别在于，那个杀人犯认罪了。
Vincent, at the time, had found Jesus in the jail. And I think he felt that Jesus might help him win some of his cases. And I also feel he didn't like the idea of pleading guilty to some crimes which we hadn't done.
文森特当时在监狱里找到了耶稣。我想他觉得耶稣可能会帮助他赢得一些案件。我也觉得他不喜欢认下一些他没做过的罪名。
Even though he had done many of those crimes, he hadn't done them all.
即使他确实做了其中的许多罪行，但他并没有全做。
Right.
对。
Now you've written about this for the Alicia Patterson Reporter. And just a few weeks ago, you went down to Joliet where Vincent is in a maximum security prison. And you talked to him about why he said no to the plea bargains, why he said no to the deal for 25 years.
现在你已经为《艾丽西亚·帕特森报道》（Alicia Patterson Reporter）写过这个故事了。就在几周前，你去了乔利特（Joliet），文森特在那里的一所最高安全级别监狱服刑。你和他谈了为什么拒绝认罪协议，为什么拒绝25年的交易。
How old were you at this time?
你当时多大？
At the time, I was 21.
当时，我21岁。
So what was going through your head?
所以你当时在想什么？
It was so many things going through my head, I can't really-- as far as the sentence was concerned, I was looking at 25 years. Half of that time would be 12 and 1/2 years.
我脑子里想的事情太多了，我真的不能——就刑期而言，我看到的是25年。那时间的一半就是12年半。
With day for day good time, 25 means you serve 12 and 1/2.
如果考虑到表现良好的减刑，25年意味着你要服刑12年半。
Exactly. And I couldn't really see 12 and 1/2 years of my life going by without me putting up a fight. I'm fighting for my life, what I felt at that particular time. I was 21 years old. I couldn't remember back 12 and 1/2 years.
确切地说。我真的无法想象在不经过抗争的情况下，我的生命就那样流逝12年半。我在为我的生命而战，那是当时我的真实感受。我才21岁。我甚至记不起12年半以前的事情。
I believe that the Lord had touched my heart and was directing me not to take this cop-out. And that was a strong conviction on my part. My family didn't understand. My attorney didn't understand. But I felt like that's the way I was being led at that time. And I still feel like that was the way that the Lord had led me to go as far as not copping out to these crimes.
我相信上帝触动了我的心，指引我不要接受这个交易。这是我内心强烈的信念。我的家人不理解。我的律师不理解。但我感到那是当时我被引领的方向。而且我依然觉得，上帝在拒绝认罪这方面指引我走那条路。
Why did you think that? You were guilty of some of these armed robberies, right?
为什么你会那么想？你当时确实犯了其中一些武装抢劫罪，对吧？
Right.
对。
So why do you think that Jesus wanted you to go to trial?
那你为什么觉得耶稣想让你接受庭审？
Well, I don't think it was so much that he wanted me to go to trial. But I felt secure in whatever I did. Whatever decision I made, I felt that the Lord was going to be with me.
嗯，我不觉得那是他想让我接受庭审。但我感觉无论我做什么都感到安心。无论我做出什么决定，我都感到上帝会与我同在。
And I don't believe that the Lord has put me here to leave me here. But I know this. That I learned a serious lesson, a serious life lesson about being in a maximum-security penitentiary. If I woulda took the cop-out, I woulda went straight to a medium-security penitentiary. I never woulda seen behind the walls of these type of penitentiaries. And I believe that, in my particular case, I needed that. I needed to know the crimes I did can call for this particular punishment and for a long period of time.
而且我不相信上帝把我放在这里是为了让我一直待在这里。但我知道一件事，我在一所最高安全级别的监狱里学到了一个严肃的教训，一个深刻的人生教训。如果我接受了那个交易，我会直接去一所中等安全级别的监狱。我永远不会见到这类监狱围墙后的景象。我相信，就我的情况而言，我需要那个。我需要知道我所犯下的罪行可能需要这种特定的惩罚以及长期的时间。
Now in the courts here in Illinois, there's something called "the tax?"
现在在伊利诺伊州的法院，有什么叫“税”吗？
Well, it's not an official term, but it's one that everyone down at 26th Street in Cook County at the courthouse recognizes. And what it is is a penalty for asserting your right to trial. In other words, if you're offered a certain number of years, if you decide to take a trial and you get found guilty, most likely, you're going to get more time than you would have if you had pled. Seems to make sense on the surface at least. Because if you didn't have that kind of an incentive, everybody would be going to trial, taking a chance on getting found innocent. And with a huge number of cases to deal with, the courts could not possibly deal with that.
嗯，这不是一个官方术语，但它是库克县第26街法院里每个人都认可的。它实际上是对行使庭审权利的惩罚。换句话说，如果给你提供了某个年限的刑期，如果你决定接受庭审而被判有罪，很可能你会得到比认罪时更多的刑期。至少表面上看是有道理的。因为如果你没有那种激励机制，每个人都会选择庭审，赌一把自己被判无罪。由于有大量的案件需要处理，法院根本无法应付。
They couldn't deal with everybody going to trial. They need people to take the plea.
他们无法处理每个人都接受庭审的情况。他们需要人们接受辩诉交易。
Well, last year in Cook County, just under 40,000 cases were disposed of by jury, by bench, and by plea. About 33,000 of those were disposed of by plea. I might add that the tax is usually greater if you insist on a jury trial instead of just a bench trial. In a bench trial, the judge decides whether you're guilty or innocent. A jury trial takes a lot longer because you have to pick a jury, you have to instruct the jury, and you have to make sure that certain evidence does not appear before the jury.
嗯，去年在库克县，有近4万起案件通过陪审团、法官审理和认罪来结案。其中大约3.3万起是通过认罪解决的。我必须补充说，如果你坚持陪审团审判而不是法官独审，这个“税”通常会更高。在法官独审中，法官决定你是否有罪。陪审团审判花费的时间要长得多，因为你必须挑选陪审团，必须指示陪审团，并且必须确保某些证据不会出现在陪审团面前。
So jury trials-- they're a nuisance for the system. They take up a lot of time. So if you go to trial and you insist on a jury trial, you're likely to get a little bit more time if you're convicted than if you just had a bench trial. So last year, as I said, 33,000 pleas. Of the other 7,000 cases, there were about 6,300 bench trials. And I believe there were just under 400 jury trials, less than 1% of the cases that were disposed of in Cook County were disposed of by a jury.
所以陪审团审判——它们对系统来说是个麻烦。它们占用大量时间。所以如果你去庭审并坚持陪审团审判，如果你被定罪，你很可能会比法官独审得到更多的时间。所以去年，就像我说的，3.3万起认罪。在剩下的7000起案件中，大约有6300起法官独审。而且我相信只有不到400起陪审团审判，库克县结案的案件中只有不到1%是通过陪审团审理的。
And is this necessarily a bad thing?
这一定是件坏事吗？
Well, I wouldn't say it's necessarily a bad thing. It depends on your philosophy. If you feel that the criminal justice system is a healthy way to deal with behavior that we don't condone, you'd probably be in favor of a tax. Because it allows the criminal justice system to work and to work even if it has rising caseloads. If you feel that society maybe should look for other ways to dissuade people from participating in activity that we don't condone, then you probably think that we should do the radical thing and abide by the Constitution, especially the Sixth Amendment, which guarantees everybody a right to a jury trial. And that's a right that's not supposed to be fettered by a tax or a punishment if you assert that right.
嗯，我不会说这一定是件坏事。这取决于你的哲学观。如果你认为刑事司法系统是处理我们不能容忍的行为的一种健康方式，你可能会支持这种“税”。因为它允许司法系统运作，即使在案件量激增的情况下也能运作。如果你认为社会也许应该寻找其他方式来劝阻人们参与我们不能容忍的活动，那么你可能会认为我们应该做些激进的事情，去遵守宪法，特别是第六修正案，它保证每个人都有权接受陪审团审判。那是一项不应该被行使该权利时的税或惩罚所束缚的权利。
And in Vincent's case, did he ask for a jury trial? Or did he get a bench trial?
在文森特的情况下，他要求陪审团审判了吗？还是法官独审？
Jury trials.
陪审团审判。
So all of these were jury trials?
所以这些全都是陪审团审判？
Right. He was a particular nuisance for the courts. His cases were taking up an awful lot of time.
对。他是法庭的一个大麻烦。他的案子占用了太多时间。
How many days are we talking about it?
我们要讨论的是多少天？
Well, it's not that many days. It's probably a day to pick the jury and a day or two of trial. But the judge in that courtroom could have disposed of many cases in the time that he had to pick juries for Vincent's cases. In that courtroom afterward, some of the regular lawyers, the lawyers assigned to the courtroom, talked about some of the prosecutors would talk to the public defenders and warn them that "You don't want your client to get Boganized, do you?"
嗯，其实没那么多天。可能是一天挑选陪审团，一两天庭审。但在文森特的案子中，那个法庭的法官本可以处理很多其他案件。在那个法庭之后，一些常规律师，指派给法庭的律师谈论道，有些检察官会警告公设辩护人：“你不想让你的客户被‘博根化’（Boganized）吧？”
"Boganized," after Vince Bogan.
“博根化”，来自文斯·博根。
That's right. Vincent was a poster boy for what happens if you assert your right to trial.
没错。文森特成了行使庭审权利后果的典型案例。
When I really look back at, OK, you offered me 25 years. Vince, you shoulda took it. Then I say, OK, if I woulda took it, I don't know. God may have had even a better blessing in store for me to take that 25 years.
当我真正回首时，好吧，你给了我25年。文斯，你应该接受它的。然后我说，好吧，如果我当时接受了，我不知道。上帝也许为我接受那25年准备了更好的祝福。
I may have went down to a medium-security penitentiary. I may have been able to continue to do the things I'm doing here in this penitentiary. My faith may have been even stronger in the Lord from that point. But I don't know. I don't know.
我可能去了中等安全级别的监狱。我可能能够继续做我在这个监狱里正在做的事情。那时我对上帝的信仰可能更坚定。但我不知道。我不知道。
But I know that God know. And I know that all things work together for the good of those who love the Lord and called according to his purpose. And that's how I was looking at this situation.
但我知道上帝知道。我知道万事互相效力，叫爱上帝的人得益处，就是按他旨意被召的人。这就是我看待这种情况的方式。
When Vincent talks about how perhaps God had him refuse the plea, it's like he's throwing himself on to a kind of a pure fatalism. Whatever will happen, will happen.
当文森特谈到上帝如何引导他拒绝认罪时，就像他陷入了一种纯粹的宿命论。无论发生什么，都会发生。
Well, I think that's right. And I think the same kind of fatalism was evident in the run Vincent had been on, the armed robberies he was pulling. I'm convinced that he wanted to get caught. He did get caught the last day after pulling three armed robberies in a row several blocks apart in the afternoon. He wasn't wearing a mask or anything. It was not intelligent work as an armed robber if that's what he was trying to do. But I think that there was an element in Vincent that wanted to be caught. Without doing much psychologizing, I'm certain that the deaths of his mom and dad played a role in that. Exactly how it led him to be doing what he was doing, I'm not certain.
嗯，我想那是对的。而且我认为同样的宿命论在他当时所做的事情、他进行的武装抢劫中也是显而易见的。我深信他想被抓到。在下午连续抢劫三起案件且相隔几个街区后，他确实在最后一天被抓到了。他没有戴口罩什么的。如果他真的想当一个成功的武装劫匪，那不是明智的行为。但我认为文森特内心有一种想被抓到的元素。不需要做太多心理分析，我肯定他父母的死亡在其中起了作用。至于它究竟如何导致他做他当时做的事情，我不确定。
In all of your talks with him, did he ever say that he felt like he wanted to be caught? Did he ever admit to that?
在你所有与他的谈话中，他有没有说过他感觉想被抓？他有没有承认过？
No, I've asked him about that. He said it was a relief when he was caught.
没有，我问过他。他说被抓是一种解脱。
I thank God for the prosecutors and judges. Romans 13 says, "Submit yourself to those who have authority over you." I believe that. If I'm wrong, that wrong should be corrected.
我感谢上帝赐予检察官和法官。罗马书13章说：“顺服掌权者。”我相信这一点。如果我错了，那个错误应该被纠正。
Just to get back to the way that he explains to himself what happened, if you think about somebody who made one decision at 21, who said, no, at 21 once essentially-- or in this case, four times in rapid succession-- and then has to live with that for the next 39 years, now that he's had a decade to think about it, it seems like there are only two ways that a person could think about it. One is, I made a terrible mistake and just be racked by that. Or the other, there was a reason, there must be a reason. In this case, God has a reason, and I will just accept that and move forward. And in a way, it's so much healthier or more life preserving for him to believe that there must be a reason that this worked out this way.
回到他解释发生在他身上事情的方式，如果你考虑一个在21岁做出一个决定的人，在21岁时本质上一次——或者在这个案例中，连续四次——说“不”，然后不得不带着那个决定生活接下来的39年。既然他已经思考了十年，似乎一个人只能有两种思考方式。一种是，我犯了一个可怕的错误，然后为此而受折磨。另一种是，有原因，一定有原因。在这个案例中，上帝有原因，我只需接受并向前看。从某种意义上说，相信一切必有原因，对他来说更健康，也更能保全自己。
Yeah, I think that Vincent is a remarkably healthy person now. And by healthy, I mean he's really adapted to his destiny. That doesn't mean that this is a success story by any means. I think it's tragic and it's mind boggling to think about someone spending the next three decades in prison who really doesn't need to be there.
是的，我认为文森特现在是一个非常健康的人。我所说的健康是指他真正适应了自己的命运。这绝不意味着这是一个成功的故事。我认为这是悲剧性的，想到一个人要在监狱里度过未来三十年，而他其实不需要待在那里，真是令人难以置信。
Vincent went into prison and very quickly started to do positive things. He's never been in any discipline problems at all in the prison since he's been incarcerated. He's worked as a photographer and the editor of The Pen News, the pentitentiary news, when he was in Pontiac. He worked jobs. He went to school. He's a painter. He does oil paintings mostly of classic cars, and he's very good at it.
文森特入狱后很快就开始做积极的事情。自从被监禁以来，他从未在监狱里出现过纪律问题。当他在庞蒂亚克（Pontiac）监狱时，他担任过摄影师和《笔尖新闻》（The Pen News）的编辑。他勤恳工作。他上学。他是个画家。他画油画，主要是老爷车，画得非常好。
Vincent was back on the right track within probably a year or two. And I don't think it was because he had a 75-year sentence hanging over his head.
文森特可能在入狱一两年内就回到了正轨。我不认为这是因为他头顶悬着75年的刑期。
If he had just 12 and 1/2 years ahead of him, probably the same thing, you're saying.
如果他面前只有12年半，你是在说可能结果也是一样。
It may have been regardless of what he had hanging over his head. He needed some time out. And most guys don't do positive time like Vincent has. There's no doubt in my mind that Vincent could have come out a few years ago and gotten a job and been a productive citizen.
无论悬在他头上的是什么，可能结果都一样。他需要一点时间。大多数人不会像文森特那样积极地度过服刑时光。毫无疑问，文森特几年前本可以出来，找到工作并成为一名多产的公民。
I was stubborn when they offered me that time really out of ignorance. I don't know why I didn't see the need to cop out for that 25 years. But I didn't. Now if I was offered that cop-out today, of course I'd take it.
当时他们给我那些时间时，我确实是因为无知而固执。我不知道为什么我当时没看出接受那25年交易的必要性。但我没看出来。现在如果今天给我那个交易，我当然会接受。
Even if it meant pleading guilty to 17?
即使这意味着承认17项罪名？
Of course. Even though that can never happen.
当然。尽管那永远不会发生了。
Steve Bogira is working on a book about a year in a courtroom here in Chicago. Vince Bogan's 75-year sentence will probably last 37 and 1/2 years because of good behavior. He'll get out around the year 2025, nearly 60 years old. If he hadn't said no to his plea bargain, he'd be out next year.
史蒂夫·博吉拉正在写一本关于在芝加哥法庭度过一年的书。由于表现良好，文斯·博根的75年刑期可能会持续37年半。他将在2025年左右出狱，接近60岁。如果他当时没对认罪交易说“不”，他明年就能出狱了。
Well, our program was produced by Susan Burton and myself with Alex Blumberg, Julie Snyder, and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Starlee Kine, Todd Bachmann, Sylvia Lemus, and Jorge Just, who ends his internship with our program today and who we wish the very best for.
好了，我们的节目由苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）协助。编辑包括保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）、杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。制作帮助来自斯塔莉·凯恩（Starlee Kine）、托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）、西尔维娅·勒姆斯（Sylvia Lemus）和豪尔赫·贾斯特（Jorge Just），他今天结束了在我们节目的实习，我们祝他一切顺利。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you know, you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
欲购买此节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。或者你知道，你可以通过我们的网站www.thislife.org在互联网上免费收听我们的大部分节目。感谢运营该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who struggles valiantly every day--
WBEZ管理层监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他每天都在英勇地奋斗——
I've devoted more of my life to thoughts of giving up than anyone else I can think of.
我一生中在“放弃”这个念头上花费的时间，比我能想到的任何人都多。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。